come on let's take a stroll down the
beach it'll be fun
[Music]
so I am gonna be taking the next week
and a half or so and basically going on
vacation I'm seeing some I'm seeing a
friend I haven't seen in a long time I
was spending some time with my partner
that I've got a family vacation with my
daughter and her mother all together and
I'm not gonna be making new videos while
that's going on
however I have done something that where
I have pre-recorded these and they will
be released as I go along and that will
be reviews of broadchurch first series
of it episode by episode so new episode
reviews daily basically until I get to
the end of the thing doctor who will
still come out on Sunday that doesn't
change but the rest of it yet that's how
I'm gonna fill out this time so that I
can you know take a break so broadchurch
is something I've been meaning to get
around to for awhile I watched the first
episode of the first series uh a while
back feels like it was about a year
maybe it wasn't that long ago but it
didn't grab me enough that I kept going
so but this time I'm committed I'm gonna
watch the entire first series and and
get through it and see what I think
about it because obviously a lot of
people have recommended it to see if it
impacts my thoughts on either Chris
Chibnall taking over as showrunner for
Doctor Who or Jodie Whittaker playing
the role of the doctor and after one
episode I can't answer those questions
that's somebody I'll probably touch back
on when I do like at the very end of all
this I might do an overview of with my
thoughts on the thing or maybe I'll wrap
it into the final episode review I don't
know we'll figure this out as we go
so broadchurch and this is these are
going to contain spoilers it's not a new
series I figure I'm safe to do that but
it opens pretty well
and it did hit me a little bit better
this time that it did on first viewing
yet at the same time watching again I
could see why it didn't grab me hard
enough that I kept I kept with it
initially so starting with the cast cast
is all good so far
they aside from Whittaker really
nobody's called on to do all that much
the guy who plays the dad honestly he
had what should have been his moment to
shine his his moment going to the to the
morgue to see the the body and I don't
know something about that moment just
didn't ring true let me put it this way
it's very obvious that this episode and
probably the show as a whole is really
going for gut punches as it goes long
and really there were only a handful of
things that actually deliver that one
obviously they were supposed to be more
so like the the father and the morgue
didn't got punch me oh yeah I suppose in
case let me ask you back up I suppose in
case you are watching this and haven't
seen the show but also don't care about
spoilers we are the the first series
deals with the death of a young boy in a
small coastal English town and the
investigation that goes on trying to
find out what happened to this boy and
how he died and who was involved with
that and it's pretty much all set up in
this first episode laying out some of
the characters are gonna be involved
which include obviously his immediate
family which is a mother father and
sister as well as a grandparent some of
the other town residents such as the guy
who Long's
runs the local newsagent where the boy
would gives paper route from we've met a
we've met a priest we've met a reporter
we've met
two cops and their boss a new to the
force is David Tennant as lead
investigator and then we have the woman
who was basically promised to that job
and then was passed over
for david tennant who wasn't even from
that town and david tennant is
apparently coming off some sort of
controversy on the last case that he
handled hasn't been blatantly addressed
yet so that's what we we've got here so
i mentioned the the father his whole
thing in the morgue looking at the body
because he's the only family member goes
and looks at it i don't know was
something artificial about it i don't
know if it was the writing or the
performance the moments that hit me
emotionally with it was basically to oh
maybe three basically any time Jodie
Whittaker broke down that hit me if
you've been watching my black mirror
reviews um you'll know I'm a really easy
target for serious emotional damage when
it comes to endangered or dead children
and the impact of those sorts of things
but before she finds out I think this
show does a really good job of
illustrating basically a parent's worst
nightmare this you know oh I'm sure
everything's fine huh he's not where I
thought he would be huh no one's seen
him at the places where normally they
would have seen him by now huh I'm sure
it's fine I'm sure it's fine I wonder
what's going on and then you know she
gets stuck in this traffic jam gets told
there's a body on the beach and she just
abandons her car and runs and when she
sees all she sees her his shoes because
the rest is under a tarp and that yeah
that hit that was solid and she has um
she has a moment of crying later on that
also rang very true she she communicates
they kind of raw emotion very well and
maybe that's the thing because she does
a really good job of bringing a reality
to the emotions you feel in the moment
whereas the the moment with the father
and the morgue it felt to it felt very
it just felt scripted it didn't feel
genuine it didn't
you raw and I don't mean that like he
should have an identical reaction to
Jodie Whittaker they're different
characters they're allowed to behave
different ways it just it felt it felt
more like acting would occur felt more
like being and you know if if that's the
level that she's gonna bring he didn't
match it the other moment that really
got me was the was the other police
investigator the one who was in David
Tennant I'm Cheryl
I'm Charles start to remember these
names after a few more episodes but her
explaining to her son who was friends
with this boy that he's dead and with
her eyes all watered up and sniffling
back tears and pain and having having to
tell her son that his best friend's dead
which of course then leads us to son
deleting a whole bunch of text messages
and stuff off his computer and we don't
know why so this is a decent enough
setup my concerns are where the balance
is going to be fine because this is very
obviously setting things up for a mix of
character drama and mystery solving
which are two things that can go quite
well together but there are also two
things that can very much distract from
each other you know when you're dealing
with a deep dive character piece having
to go through the logistics of a mystery
investigation can give some of that
character development or arcs or
whatever the short shrift on the flip
side if you keep diving into you know
the motivations histories of these
characters it can leave people who are
here for the mystery going okay I don't
care how was this done so getting that
balance in of itself is going to be
tricky and then I will be curious as it
goes along to see if I get a sense of
whether it is intended to be more of a
mystery or more of a character drama i
I'm I'm not sure which one I would
prefer inherently I kind of inclined
towards mystery a little bit more
but you know I will be really curious
anything maintaining the balance is
gonna be the thing because we've met an
interesting cast of characters enough
questions have been raised there's a
little bit of intrigue and the
information we've gotten on the
character so far all feels relevant it's
just a question of whether or not that
that remains I think one last total side
note before I wrap this one up right now
the character that I'm the angriest at
isn't whoever killed the boy not that
I'm like okay with that because you know
I'm not whoever it was should definitely
get what's coming to them by it there's
a reporter from a bigger newspaper comes
into town and she goes to the spot on
the beach where people have been leaving
you know flowers bouquets pictures etc
and the boy's sister had left a stuffed
monkey presumably one that had belonged
to Danny to the young boy and this
reporter takes it and puts it in her
purse and leaves with it I don't know
why I don't know what she intends to do
with it but it immediately made me hate
her a hell of a lot more than anybody
else in this thing it's a bit how I
think a lot of Harry Potter fans hate
Dolores Umbridge a lot more than they
hate Voldemort like I understand the guy
who killed a kid is worse than this
reporter who is just removing a a symbol
of a sister's love to her dead brother
but I'm sorry I hate her more right now
in the incident of of having to watch it
so I hope I'm supposed to hate her
cuz I do yeah so I think that's it this
is episode one abroad Church there are
eight episodes I believe in the first
series so we'll see how this goes it's a
it's a good solid setup like I said it
didn't like you truly get its hooks into
me but it is intriguing and I am curious
to see how it pans out and where things
go from here so
Oh broadchurch episode 1 I'm assuming
you've probably seen he's been out for a
while but whatever your thoughts on it
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it please don't put
suppose for later episodes for the
courtesy of other viewers stick to the
episodes that are actually the ones
being reviewed or the ones prior as we
go along with all this so that'll do it
folks thanks so much for watching
there's all the stuff to do like support
me on patreon and follow me on Twitter
or listen to my podcast links for all
that stuff and more is down in the
description so until next time it's
councils adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]